[Music]
earlier this week we presented the city
of chicago with a massive conan
bobblehead you know
my gift to you
yeah
we spent the whole week looking for a
chicago location to put the bobble head
viewers sent in some great suggestions
like
putting the bobble head on a tour of the
chicago river
putting the bubble head on top of the
willis tower
and having it soak up the rays on oak
street
beach oh
yeah there it is
yeah
which
i can't do that but the bubble again
they were all great suggestions but
there's only one home for a cultural
icon like the conan bobblehead the art
institute of chicago
yeah
isn't that amazing the artist dude in
chicago well guess what ladies and
gentlemen
we trucked it there this morning take a
look this is exciting
that's right we felt a great art museum
deserves great art
so it yes at great expense we had the
conan bobblehead trucked
to the museum
it was installed there
a crowd formed
and just massive excitement
we thought this is
i thought
i thought this is the perfect place for
the bobble head well guess what the art
institute they felt differently
get it out of here you brought it here
you can take it out of here i guess
you're right
sorry but off it goes
to be fair we didn't ask them first
so we took it to the only place that
actually invited us to put up the bobble
head it's now displaying the specials at
harold's chicken shack store number 62
on wabash
avenue yes
yep
and that's where it stays until the cops
make us move it
that's my solemn promise to you